opposition protesters in Bangladesh are
demanding the resignation of the
government because of rising food prices
and the lack of political Freedom
supporters of the main opposition party
and Marching In the capital Dhaka
they're demanding a non-partisan
caretaker government before the
presidential election later this year
and the release of political prisoners
over to Tampa child who joins us live
from Dhaka and tanvir how big are these
protests so far and what's driving
people onto the streets
well this rally was big it was uh
several kilometers long it's essentially
a road March it started from a area
called guaptoli in the city and most of
the Israelis were heading to the center
of the city and other parts of the city
tens of thousands of people participated
in the Israelis their one key demand is
resignation of the government and they
want a neutral caretaker government to
take over before the general election
which is supposed to take place on
December January next year now many of
these people who were in the rally are
not necessarily members of political
parties we met people from different
walks of life from cab drivers to truck
drivers to scooter drivers to Rickshaw
polar they said that they're upset with
the government because of the economic
crisis the food pres food prices and
Essentials are very high high inflation
rate people are having real hard time
since last year and the government has
been able to tackle those and they want
the government to resign unless they
take care of the economic situation
question now even on last week on
Wednesday there was a massive rally by
the opposition where they declared this
one point demand from the center of the
capital literally hundreds of thousands
of people took place in this rallies and
this key demand Remains the one point uh
between the opposition party and its 36
party Alliance in terms of as you say
there given that we've got elections
taking place later this year how might
all of this affect that that key vote
well it's increasingly taking a
confrontational turn I mean the
government is adamant they said the
election will take place it will be free
and neutral but it will be under this
present government they will remain in
power and they will not resign because
under the Constitution they said there's
no provision for uh caretaker neutral
government and also in the street even
today there has been clashes between
opposition uh supporters and the ruling
parties supporters yesterday that was a
major by-election when one of the
independent major candidates was beaten
up by the ruling party supporters so
this sort of Confrontation and
increasingly when the opposition puts
out a rally the government supporters
also puts out a rally and it is
increasingly getting towards the
confrontational politics unless they sit
down and come to some sort of dialogue
there's high level visit from the United
States state department the EU and the
U.N trying to sort of mediate and
encourage a fair action despite all this
both sides seems to be adamant and both
side is sticking to their demands and
obviously before the election we'll see
more rallies more confrontation unless
there is a some sort of understanding
between the two main opposition party
and the ruling party it sounds like a
lot of political turbulence to come
Sanford in Dhaka thank you